كان هذا اليوم الموعود للاستيلاء على
باقمه الاوكرانيه رمزيه النصر في يوم
النصر وفقا لقائد قوات باجنر والقياده
الروسيه ايضا لكنه تحول الى اعنف هجوم
يشنه يفجن بريكوجين على قيادات الكريمه
لا يجب ان يموت الجندي بسبب الغباء المطلق
للقياده في موسكو الجنرالات والضباط على
الارض ملزمون بتنفيذ هذا الغباء لان
الاوامر التي تصلهم من الاعلى هي اجراميه
بكل ما تحمله الكلمه من معنى غباء القياده
هذا ليس الاحتراف الوحيد الذي كشفه زعيم
قوات فاجنر فالرجل رفع من سقف حربه مع
رجال الكرملين حددت تشكيك بقدره الحكومه
الروسيه في الدفاع عن البلاد
اوكرانيا تضرب المناطق الحدوديه الروسيه
بنجاح لماذا الدوله الروسيه غير قادره على
الدفاع عن البلاد
جنرالات كانوا مشغولين بنصب المكائد بدلا
من القتال يقول
انعكس على جبهات القتال ودفعت جنود الروس
الى الفرار من ساحات المعارك جبن مبطن
للجيش تهمهم به طبخ بوتين كما كان يطلق
عليه فوفقا للرجل فان وحده عسكريه روسيه
فرت مؤخرا من مواقعها قرب بخموت ما جعلت
جبهه مكشوفه على خطوط القتال التي تتمركز
فيه قواته كما لم تتلقى مجموعته سوى عشره
بالمئه من الذخيره اللازمه للقتال امر
اعتبره الرجل جريمه لتدمير الشعب الروسي
ايام وتنسحب فاجنر من تخوم باخموت يقول
يفغيني فحتى بوتين مخدوع من قبل جنرالته
في الحمله العسكريه في اوكرانيا خداع قال
انهم سيدفعون ثمنه على يد القائد او الشعب
الروسي اذا خسر الحرب رائد المصطفى
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات